Underpants for your hands and an r2d2
space heater it's episode four of loot
let's start today with Etsy if you're
cold cover up with a hat and face mask
that doubles as an epic beard and if you
want to be more sci-fi throw on a
Cthulhu knit head warmer it's got a
mouth hole if you prefer the fabric off
your face by this Mario Piranha Plants
scarf and then throw a fiesta with a
pinata shaped like a uterus complete
with fallopian tubes we've all seen the
snow-white Apple laptop decals you can
buy but don't forget nerdy snow white
ninja snow white or wicked snow white
then curl up with one of Yenko designs
fluffy cuddly light-up pillows once
comfortable sip some tea like an angry
person with their brass knuckle mugs or
really kill some time with this gun
trigger mug if you prefer emotions pick
up their mood mugs or go all out with a
face mug whose mouth can store cookies
make a delicious cookie with this fetus
shaped cookie cutter or be a food
scientist with 50 collec euler cuisine
starter kit this kit comes with special
thickeners emulsifiers and binders that
let you learn while cooking up things
like firm fruit juice caviar and beef
foam after that you might want to be
more organic so finish the meal with
pink geeks edible giant toasted hands
high in protein low in saturated fat now
if only we had plates to eat them off of
oh cool back to Etsy for some hilarious
vintage plates I especially love the
businessman cat plate if you're on a
diet just stick to smelling scented
markers no these are scented pens and
look why not cover another mug this one
makes it look like you're drinking out
of a toilet because you've always wanted
to as such you might like this calendar
containing artistic shots of dog poop or
this nicer one containing photos of cute
baby animals being held by manly men
this iPhone wrap uses vinyl woodgrain an
actual skateboard grip tape to make your
phone a board and last but not
a Stephen Colbert couch you can buy
everything in this episode by following
links in this video's description let me
know in the comments below
whose face would you want on your couch
subscribe to Vsauce 2 for more and as
always thanks for watching